one of the things that I like about
national review and always liked about
national review is that we weren't just
there to go off to the left which we do
but we were also there to police our own
side and I've tried to keep that up hi
I'm Nicholas P with recent TV and we're
talking with Charles W Cooke he is the
newly appointed editor of National
Review Online and the author of the
Conservatorium manifesto thanks for
talking to us thank you for having me
you are also originally from Britain
until you migrated this way what's your
take on brexit I was Pro I was pleased I
was in England I didn't expect it to
happen I'd hoped it would happen for
probably 20 years long before I was
political actually is there anything
good about the EU that gets lost if
England moves out of it that's the
debate so I'm going to tell you first
why I was in favor of it and then we can
come onto that because that's a really
important point I've been in favour of
Britons leaving the EU for a long time
because I'm in favor of sovereignty to
me if you are going to have a parliament
you should be bound by that Parliament
on this I was with the British Socialist
Tony Benn you've got to be able to
defeat the people who govern you
probably the only thing I ever agree
with him on and he said it would be
theft of public rights to say to
somebody vote for me and I will look
after your interests Oh actually I've
loaned those powers elsewhere now there
seems to have been a small majority in
Britain in favour of that proposition
but there's now going to be an almighty
fight as to what the Parliament does
with that power when it's repatriated
but I think for many people who voted
for it this was a question of outcomes
they thought well if we leave the EU we
get rid of free migration we leave the
EU we get rid of the free trade
agreements if we leave the EU we get rid
of this regulation or that regulation
that's not necessarily the case one of
the things that a lot of people we're
trying to do is to take the the energy
and the Animus and the anger behind
brexit and say okay this is parallel to
something going on with Trump National
Review back in December of course came
out with a never Trump issue is there a
meaningful parallel between these events
or the energy
and if it's good to brakes it in England
is it you know does that mean that Trump
should be given a second look in America
on the last question no there is a
parallel but there's also a difference
so the parallel is that some of the
people who voted for brexit are annoyed
with what they think of as negative
globalization they're annoyed with
immigration they're annoyed with free
trade they think that Britain is being
sold out to this invisible cabal and I
think you see that within the Trump
movement where it's different is there's
also a lot of if you will never Trump us
who would have been Pro brexit because
they would have believed in
old-fashioned ideas like sovereignty of
sort of constitutional integrity
I don't think personally it helps Trump
firstly Britain as a different country
has a different culture secondly it's a
different question do you wish to change
the way your country relates with the
world
in terms of its fundamental sovereignty
from do you wish this person to be
President and I think what we're seeing
thus far at least is people don't want
Trump to be their president in your
stimulating and popular but the
Conservatorium manifesto who were the
conservatory ins going to vote for in
election 2016 well that's a fascinating
question I think the Republican Party
essentially read my book insofar as he
did at all and said let's not do this so
anyone who liked the book I think you're
giving them too much credit for reading
but anyone who who liked the book
probably is not voting for Trump I think
that Gary Johnson is popular but I also
think there are a lot of people at least
in my email INBOX would suggest though a
lot of people who read my book who want
to reclaim the Republican Party but
certainly can't do so until November you
were recently named the editor of
National Review Online which was really
one of the first and still one of the
best most certainly most trafficked but
also most provocative websites for a
political magazine what direction do you
see the site moving under your
editorship and what are areas new areas
or new writers new things that you're
looking to do well I think we have a
pretty good offering a cities certainly
our position against Trump is unlikely
to change and one of the things that I
like about National Review and always
liked about National
you is that we weren't just there to go
after the left which we do but we were
also there to police our own side and
I've tried to keep that up I think it's
extremely important to call out people
who are nominally with you and whether
it's because they're crony capitalists
whether it's because they are crooked or
whether it's because they're you know in
hock to somebody I think in Donald Trump
is a charlatan I think that's important
also I have a slightly more libertarian
bent so that'll probably shine through a
little bit National Review has always
been a magazine on a website that is
included a number of viewpoints I hope
that will continue but the editor
probably has some stamp on it so it
should move slightly more on the
libertarian direction but I can't
imagine that it will change too much
because I think it was pretty good in
the first place all right well thank you
we'll leave it there thank you we have
been talking with Charles W Cook of
National Review he's the new editor of
National Review Online and the author of
the Conservatorium manifesto thanks so
much for talking
I think you've Avenue for recent TV I'm
Nikolas